you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on test comms
tactics trainer it's been a while for
this one but I'm going to tackle another
group of three puzzles and just share my
thoughts along the way okay we're
playing as white and we're not going to
be able to give mate to the king so I'm
wondering if there's a way to pick up
the Queen somehow
now why do I say there isn't a way to
give me maybe maybe there is maybe there
is let's not be too quick so somehow if
the king is on b4 and we can get to c3
with check that'll force king a4 and
then queen a3 now probably is a mate
come to think of it cuz I see the answer
now okay I was just going to discount
the win of the Queen because I didn't
quite see how to hit black with the
skewer you know getting the Queen on
this diagonal with the King being in a
c4 d5 we could force that
so we could start with this check if
King before in fact Queen takes b5 is
mate so Queen check King takes e4 will
then be met with queen c3 forcing king D
5 and then Queen b3 will pick up the
Queen I don't think there's much more to
go over
that's the only thing really just two
moves okay so let's put it on and see
what the computer goes for okay so in
two moves we're now going to get a
skewer the Queen pair the king and queen
all right that'll do it let's try one
more or puzzle two of three team black
okay
well there aren't any good checks on
move one
so the first move that captures my
attention is a Brooke lift and lights
given a move a check here
King g7 and then what where's the
follow-up check nothing good our rook
still covers 'if I've we wouldn't want
to go to h7 because if Queen takes f7
mate so I'm just thinking rook to e3
looking at rook takes pawn and then
White has to give up the Queen for the
rook otherwise Queen g3 as a follow up
is mate is that really all there is to
this one okay well you know it's
probably a bit more tricky than that
because rookie 2 is pretty forceful as
well in fact how would you even prevent
mate with Queen to g2 if I start with
the rook here that's probably better
yeah because another thing is there's a
lot of poems so maybe maybe white could
somehow give up the Queen for the rook
and run with this guy he is only two
steps away
he could be tough to track down so it's
probably you don't even allow white an
opportunity to sack the clean for the
rook you just go in for rookie too and I
just don't see how white stop squeegee
to mate let's test something though I've
already worked out the checks they don't
really lead to anything rook a a King g7
the end so rookie to suppose the King
tries to run what can we do there Queen
G to this forces King f4
we have another check
Queen h2
back to G for a rook is controlling all
the e-file squares on has this one so
once the king is on g4 then our Rick
comes over to G to our queen and rook
will be on these two squares and a
couple cover all the squares from the
white king it must just be ripped to e2
I don't have to really consider anything
else and it's check just step up and
okay so that's that's what they're going
for but in this case I guess I probably
still should have looked at this one
because I was voicing that is trying to
avoid a situation where y could even
give up the Queen for the rook but in
this case we're going to pick up the
rook in the corner take the Queen and
then take the pawn with the fork on a
king and rook so that and then this and
we pick up the rook in the corner okay
let's try one last one ooh blue
team black this is interesting my first
impression was I thought that we were
going to be able to mate but that's not
the case if there was a white pawn here
would we be able to win no I was
thinking of a puzzle where I think we
would need a pawn on this square or
something yeah I'm trying to think if
this pawn was here and there was another
white pawn here it would be a win for
black yeah if this pond was here and
white had an additional pawn at a five
black would win by playing here pawn
push King back here and the pawn has to
move and then you take the pawn for me
anyhow that was my first just at a quick
glance I thought this was going to be a
win but uh I'm thinking we have to
somehow draw this
oh so the drawing method must be to
approach these pawns from behind because
going to c5 allows King to a5 our pawn
can't move then we're very limited candy
for King here and we're just not winning
that so I believe the trick will be to
go to c3 and move one there are many
options for light if the King moves then
we pick up the b-pawn we keep pressure
on this pond and we're ready to run with
the C pawn so I'm thinking king c3 and I
think the computer will go well we'll
find out I think on b4 we would then
play to be 2 at the King and this will
force the King away from the a pond and
in the end if these pawns are a knight's
move away from one another they'll both
end up just getting traded off as long
as one of the things it isn't way out of
position and in this specific case
neither King will be way out of position
so I think it's just came to c3 and we
keep pressure on the pawns from behind
so let's put it on going with B 4 and
now we approach from behind and we could
take here and just take the pond soon
enough another case of these pawns being
a knight move away King takes pawn and
King takes pawn and draw ok that wasn't
a bad group of three that last one this
one here caught me a bit by surprise
does anyone know exactly what I'm
talking about I hope I was clear with
that endgame
one right here where I was saying
if this guy was on a six and white hat
upon on a five has anyone else seen that
puzzle I don't know if it's something
that I've shared before in this playlist
but it's a cool one for sure some type
of end game study I imagine
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video how'd you do with
these three let me know in the comment
section below and I will catch you soon
that's all for now take care bye
you